San Diego Comic-Con has revealed some super-special
news for the CW's Arrowverse - and it's a
development we never thought we'd ever see.
A familiar face is donning Superman's cape
once again, and he has some feelings about
the impending comeback.
As part of the festivities of Comic-Con 2019,
it was announced that the CW is cooking up
a crossover of epic proportions: former Superman
actor Brandon Routh, who played Clark Kent
in the 2006 film Superman Returns, and current
Man of Steel Tyler Hoechlin, who portrays
Supes in a recurring capacity on Supergirl,
will both be suiting up as Superman as a part
of the Arrowverse's upcoming "Crisis on Infinite
Earths" event.
It's a role Routh hasn't played since 2006's
Superman Returns, and at this point, almost
certainly never expected to play again.
"He was Superman.
Everyone was in love with him."
The announcement, first reported by Deadline
on July 19, got fans in the best kind of huff:
a fast-talking frenzy that left some commenters
already declaring "Crisis on Infinite Earths"
as the greatest crossover event ever.
Not long after the news hit the 'net, Routh
took to social media just like the fans did
to react to his return as Superman.
"I think it's only fair that I answer."
Routh tweeted in response to Deadline's post
confirming the news, saying that he was
"Honored, humbled, grateful, and still pinching
myself."
Hoechlin, who first slipped into the Superman
suit in 2016 for Supergirl, expressed his
own anticipation for the forthcoming clash
of the Supermen by tweeting at Routh,
"Let's go brother!"
Routh bantered back with a punch and a wink
emoji, as well as the comment,
"So excited to share the screen with you as
Supes @tylerhoechlin!
So fun!
I'm so ready!"
Routh also joked that he was immediately heading
off to the gym to get into tip-top shape for
the crossover, though we doubt he actually
needs to, considering that he's been playing
superheroes for years.
Arrowverse loyals will already recognize Routh
from his role as Ray Palmer, better known
as the Atom -- a role which he's taken to
Arrow, The Flash, and DC's Legends of Tomorrow,
on which he's currently a main player.
The actor also opened up to Entertainment
Weekly about his return to the role that put
him on the map as a younger man.
He admitted that he initially experienced
mixed feelings about the news before letting
himself feel excited.
Asked about his outlook, Routh said,
"It's an opportunity for me to kind of say
hello and goodbye to the character in a way
I didn't get to the first time."
"Being a young individual of 24, 25, I thought,
'Oh, I'm going to do this for years and make
multiple movies.'
And that of course didn't happen.
I'm just very honored to do this one last
time."
Routh and Hoechlin's eagerness about playing
duelling Supermen is nothing compared to the
reactions of their fans, one of whom tweeted,
"The fact that both of you will be sharing
the screen as Supes is blowing my mind!
Can't wait to see you both back in the red
cape!"
Another said that the news was the best thing
they had heard yet from this year's Comic-Con
- even more incredible than the surprise Top
Gun: Maverick trailer Tom Cruise dropped on
Thursday.
According to that fan,
"I was buzzing like a happy bee over the Top
Gun trailer… then this Brandon Routh news
drops into my hive like a dollop of sweet
unpasteurized honey.
Yes!
Best DC news in ever."
What makes the news of Routh's return to the
Superman role so exciting is that many thought
it would never be possible.
The idea of seeing Routh as Kal-El again was
pretty unthinkable after Superman Returns
failed to generate the kind of box office
that studio Warner Brothers Pictures needed
to greenlight a sequel, taking in just over
$391 million worldwide.
That's not much compared to other DC Comics-based
fare from WB, which has tended to scoop up
anywhere from around $750 million globally
on the lower end to over $1 billion at the
top.
While Routh did pick up praise for his performance,
Warner Bros. decided not to pursue more films
with him in the role.
The studio wound up rebooting the character
seven years later in 2013's Man of Steel,
the film that started the DC Extended Universe
as we know it.
It's unknown which installments of the five-episode
"Crisis on Infinite Earths" event Routh and
Hoechlin will appear on.
Much like previous crossover events in the
Arrowverse, the expansive story is set to
once again bring together the casts of the
CW's superhero series, this time including
Arrow, Batwoman, The Flash, Legends of Tomorrow,
and Supergirl.
Even without the Superman news, it's clear
that the event will be the biggest one in
the Arrowverse thus far, spanning two months
of real time, with three episodes of the crossover
seeing release in December, and two more to
follow in January 2020.
The crossover's story is likely to follow,
or at least draw inspiration from, the DC
Comics storyline of the same name, in which
the heroes fight against the nefarious Anti-Monitor
with the help of alternate versions of themselves
from different universes.
With that story as a jumping off point, "Crisis
on Infinite Earths" was already shaping up
to be unlike anything Arrowverse fans had
seen prior to this announcement - but now,
it's simply superb.
Two Supermans at the same time is just the
icing on the cake, and we're glad that Routh
thinks the news is as sweet as we do.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.